buenos días me llamo steve de vancouver
en canadá
y mi pasión es el aprendizaje de idiomas
y por eso he desarrollado con mi hijo un
sistema de aprendizaje que se llama link
que es modificar
yo hablo como 18 idiomas
ahí dio a idiomas que hablo más mejor
que el español y menos bien que el
español porque nunca he vivido en españa
pero he visitado
ya veces cada vez una semana pero he
leído mucho en español ellos he
escuchado mucho en español y lo que se
sabe ahora del aprendizaje de idiomas es
que lo más importante para adquirir
adquirir un idioma es lo que se llama en
inglés el import es decir escuchar y
leer por qué
alguien puede escuchar donde sea y leer
cuando quiera pero es más difícil poder
conversar con un nativo en el idioma que
estamos aprendiendo claro que el aula es
una ocasión de encontrar otro amigos que
están estudiando el mismo idioma y el
profesor el enseñante puede ser un un
estímulo
animarnos
explicar cosas pero lo demás tenemos que
hacerlo nos mismos los mismos en un
sistema de import
bien organizado y por eso el sistema
link es una sistema donde se puede
encontrar contenidos de todo tipo a todo
lo que cada nivel con audio y texto
y hay un montón de funciones que nos
ayudan a aprender palabras y frases
porque lo que tenemos que hacer es
adquirir palabras y frases para que
podemos comprender el idioma y para qué
tenemos
armas palabras y frases para poder
exprimir lo que queremos decir
con este base después se puede
desarrollar está
facilidad de hablar no pero sobre todo
lo más importante este es mi experiencia
porque he aprendido muchos idiomas es
y hacer crecer el vocabulario y alcanzar
a un nivel de comprensión que nos
permite en cada situación de comprender
lo que el otro está diciendo y poder
gozar de películas o poder leer libros
para entrar en el idioma y cuando
tenemos esta
profundidad en el idioma
en la expresión oral todo esto se puede
puede desarrollar naturalmente por eso
yo creo que el sistema link que yo
utilizo utilizó de desde 10 años y ahora
por el árabe por el coreano por ruso por
otros idiomas es una manera por el el
aprenden te que aprende
independientemente y también por el
estudiante que aprende en el aula y en
la sala de clases
espero que vosotros tenéis la ocasión de
probarlo
y beneficiar de bueno de toda la
experiencia que yo tengo es que está la
base de nuestro sistema
mucho gusto
buena suerte
[Música]